[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
how do you explain
when things don't go as we assume or
better
how do you explain when others are able
to achieve things that seem to defy all
of the assumptions
for example why is apple so innovative
year after year after year after year
they're more innovative than
all their competition and yet they're
just a computer company
they're just like everyone else they
have the same access to the same talent
the same agencies the same consultants
the same media
then why is it that they seem to have
something different
why is it that martin luther king led
the civil rights movement
he wasn't the only man who suffered in a
pre-civil rights america
and he certainly wasn't the only great
orator of the day why him
and why is it that the wright brothers
were able to figure out
control powered man flight when there
were certainly other teams who were
better qualified better funded
and they didn't achieve powered man
flight the wright brothers beat them to
it
there's something else at play here
about
three and a half years ago i made a
discovery
and this discovery profoundly changed my
view
on how i thought the world worked and it
even profoundly changed the way in which
i operate in it
as it turns out there's a pattern as it
turns out
all the great and inspiring leaders and
organizations in the world whether it's
apple or martin luther king or the
wright brothers
they all think act and communicate the
exact
same way and it's the complete opposite
to everyone else all i did was codify it
and it's probably the world's simplest
idea
i call it the golden circle
why how what this little idea
explains why some organizations and some
leaders are able to inspire
where others aren't let me define the
terms really quickly
every single person every single
organization on the planet knows
what they do 100 some
know how they do it whether you call it
your differentiating value proposition
or your proprietary process or your usp
but very very few people or
organizations
know why they do what they do and by why
i don't mean to make a profit
that's a result it's always a result by
why i mean what's your purpose
what's your cause what's your belief why
does your organization
exist why do you get out of bed in the
morning
and why should anyone care well as a
result the way we think the way we act
the way we communicate
is from the outside in it's obvious we
go from the clearest thing to the
fuzziest thing
but the inspired leaders and the inspire
or inspired organizations
regardless of their size regardless of
their industry
all think act and communicate from the
inside out let me give you an example
i use apple because they're easy to
understand and everybody gets it
if apple were like everyone else
a marketing message from them might
sound like this
we make great computers they're
beautifully designed
simple to use and user friendly want to
buy one
and that's how most of us communicate
that's how most marketing is done that's
how most sales done and that's how most
of us communicate into personally we say
what we do we say how we're different or
how we better we expect some sort of
behavior or purchase a vote something
like that here's our new law firm
we have the best lawyers with the
biggest clients we have you know we
always perform for our clients do
business with us here's our new car
it gets great gas mileage it has you
know leather seats
by our car but it's uninspiring here's
how apple
actually communicates everything we do
we believe in challenging the status quo
we believe in thinking differently
the way we challenge the status quo is
by making our products beautifully
designed
simple to use and user friendly we just
happen to make great computers
want to buy one totally different right
you're ready to buy a computer from me
all i did was reverse the order of the
information
what it proves to us is that people
don't buy what you do people by why you
do it people don't buy what you do they
buy why you do it
this explains why every single person in
this room
is perfectly comfortable buying a
computer from apple
but we're also perfectly comfortable
buying an mp3 player from apple
or a phone from apple or a dvr from
apple
but as i said before apple's just a
computer company there's nothing that
distinguishes them
structurally from any of their
competitors their competitors are all
equally qualified to make all of these
products in fact they tried
a few years ago gateway came out with
flat screen tvs
they're eminently qualified to make flat
screen tvs they've been making flat
screen monitors for years
nobody bought one
dell came out with mp3 players and pdas
and they make great quality products and
they can make perfectly well designed
products
and nobody bought one in fact talking
about it now we can't even imagine
buying
an mp3 player from dell why would you
buy an mp3 player from a computer
company
but we do it every day people don't buy
what you do they buy why you do it
the goal is not to do business with
anybody with everybody who needs what
you have
the goal is to do business with people
who believe what you believe
here's the best part none of what i'm
telling you is my opinion
it's all grounded in the tenets of
biology not psychology
biology if you look at a cross section
of the human brain looking from the top
down
what you see is the human brain is
actually broken into three major
components
that correlate perfectly with the golden
circle
our newest brain our homo sapien brain
our neocortex
corresponds with the what level the
neocortex is responsible for all of our
rational
and analytical thought and language
the middle two sections make up our
limbic brains
and our limbic brains are responsible
for all of our feelings
like trust and loyalty it's also
responsible for all human
behavior all decision making and it has
no capacity for language in other words
when we communicate from the outside in
yes people can understand
vast amounts of complicated information
like features and benefits and facts and
figures
it just doesn't drive behavior when we
communicate from the inside out
we're talking directly to the part of
the brain that controls behavior
and then we allow people to rationalize
it with the tangible things we say and
do
this is where gut decisions come from
you know sometimes
you can give somebody all the facts and
figures and they say i know what all the
facts and details say but
it just doesn't feel right why would we
use that verb it doesn't feel right
because the part of the brain that
controls decision making doesn't control
language
and the best we can muster up is i don't
know it just doesn't feel right
or sometimes you say you're leading with
your heart or you're leading with your
soul well i hate to break it to you
those aren't
other body parts controlling your
behavior it's all happening here in your
limbic brain the part of the brain that
controls decision making
and not language but if you don't know
why you do what you do
and people respond to why you do what
you do then how will anybody
how would you ever get people to to to
vote for you or buy something from you
or more importantly
be loyal and want to be a part of what
it is what you that you do
again the goal is not just to sell
people who need what you have the goal
is to sell to people who believe what
you believe
the goal is not just to hire people who
need a job
it's to hire people who believe what you
believe
i always say that you know this if you
if you if you um hire people just
because they can do a job they'll work
for your money but if you hire people
who believe what you believe they work
for you with
blood and sweat and tears and nowhere
nowhere else is there a better example
of this than with the wright brothers
most people don't know about samuel
pierpont langley
and back in the early 20th century the
pursuit of powered man flight was like
the dot com of the day
everybody was trying it and samuel
pierpont langley had what we assume
to be the recipe for success i mean
even now you ask people why did your
product or why did your company fail and
people always give you the
same permutation of the same three
things under capitalized the wrong
people
bad market conditions it's always the
same three things so let's explore that
samuel pierpont langley was given fifty
thousand dollars by the war department
to figure out this
flying machine money was no problem he
held a
seat at harvard and worked at the
smithsonian and was extremely well
connected he knew all the big minds of
the day
he hired the best minds money could find
and the market conditions were fantastic
the new york times followed him around
everywhere and everyone was rooting for
langley
and how come we've never heard of samuel
pierpont langley
a few hundred miles away in dayton ohio
orville and wilbur wright they had none
of what we consider to be the recipe for
success they had no money
they paid for their dream with the
proceeds from their bicycle shop
not a single person on the wright
brothers team had a college education
not even orville or wilbur and the new
york times followed them around
nowhere the difference was orville and
wilbur
were driven by a cause by a purpose by a
belief they believed that if they could
figure out this flying machine it'll
change the course of the world
samuel pierpont langley was different he
wanted to be rich
and he wanted to be famous he was in
pursuit of the result he was in pursuit
of the riches
and lo and behold look what happened the
people who believed
in the wright brothers dream worked with
them for with blood and sweat and tears
the others just worked for the paycheck
and they tell stories of how every time
the wright brothers went out
they would have to take five sets of
parts because that's how many times they
would
crash before they came in for supper
and eventually on december 17th 1903
the wright brothers took flight and no
one was there to even
experience it we found out about it a
few days later
and further proof that langley was
motivated by the wrong thing
the day the wright brothers took flight
he quit
he could have said that's an amazing
discovery guys and i will improve upon
your technology
but he didn't he wasn't first he didn't
get rich he didn't get famous
so he quit people don't buy what you do
they buy why you do it
and if you talk about what you believe
you will attract those who believe what
you believe
well why is it important to attract
those who believe what you believe
something called the law of diffusion of
innovation and if you don't know the law
you definitely know the terminology
the first two and a half percent of our
population are our
innovators the next 13 and a half
percent of our population
are our early adopters the next 34
are your early majority your late
majority and your
the only reason these people buy touch
tone phones is because you can't buy
rotary phones anymore
[Music]
we all sit at various places at various
times on the scale but the law of
diffusion of innovation tells us
is that if you want mass market success
or mass-market acceptance of an idea
you cannot have it until you achieve
this tipping point
between 15 and 18 market penetration
and then the system tips and i love
asking businesses what's your conversion
on new business and they love to tell
you oh it's about 10
proudly well you can trip over 10 of the
customers we all have about 10
who just get it that's how we describe
them right that's like that gut feeling
oh they just get it the problem is how
do you
find the ones that just get it before
you're doing business with them versus
the ones
who don't get it so it's this
here this little gap that you have to
close as jeffrey moore calls it
crossing the chasm because you see the
early majority
will not try something until someone
else
has tried it first and these guys
the innovators and the early adopters
they're comfortable making those gut
decisions
they're more comfortable making those
intuitive decisions that are driven
by what they believe about the world
and not just what product is available
these are the people who stood online
for six hours to buy an iphone when they
first came out when you could have just
walked into the store the next week and
bought one off the shelf
these are the people who spent forty
thousand dollars on flat screen tvs when
they first came out
even though the technology was
substandard and by the way they didn't
do it because the technology was so
great
they did it for themselves it's because
they wanted to be first
people don't buy what you do they buy
why you do it and what you do simply
proves what you believe in fact people
will do the things that prove what they
believe
the reason that person bought the iphone
on the first in the first
six hours or stood in line for six hours
was because of what they believed about
the world and how they wanted everybody
to see them
they were first people don't buy what
you do they buy why you do it
so let me give you a famous example a
famous
failure and a famous success of the law
of diffusion of innovation
first the famous failure it's a
commercial example
as we said before a second ago the
recipe for success is money and the
right people in the right marketing
conditions right you should have success
then
look at tivo from the time tevo came out
about eight or nine years ago to this
current day
they are the single highest quality
product on the market
hands down there is no dispute they were
extremely well funded market conditions
were fantastic
i mean we use tivo as a verb like tivo
stuff on my piece of junk time warner
dvr all the time
but tivo's commercial failure they've
never made money
and when they went ipo their stock was
at about 30 or 40
then plummeted and it's never traded
above 10. in fact i don't think that's
even traded above
six except for a couple of little spikes
because you see when tivo launched their
product
they told us all what they had they said
we have a product
that pauses live tv skips commercials
rewinds live tv and memorizes your
viewing habits without you even asking
the cynical majority said we don't
believe you
we don't need it we don't like it you're
scaring us
what if they had said if you're the kind
of person
who likes to have total control over
every aspect of your life
boy do we have a product for you it
pauses live tv skips commercials
memorizes your viewing habits etc etc
people don't buy what you do they buy
why you do it and what you do simply
serves as the proof
of what you believe now let me give you
a
successful example of the law of
diffusion of innovation
in the summer of 1963
000 people showed up on the mall in
washington to hear
dr king speak they sent out no
invitations
and there was no website to check the
date how do you do that
well dr king wasn't the only man in
america
who was the who was a great orator he
wasn't the only man in america who
suffered in a pre-civil rights america
in fact some of his ideas were bad
but he had a gift he didn't go around
telling people what needed to change in
america
you know he went around and told people
what he believed i believe
i believe i believe he told people and
people who believed what he believed
took his cause and they made it their
own and they told people
and some of those people created
structures to get the word out to even
more people
and lo and behold 250 000 people showed
up on the right day
on the right time to hear him speak
how many of them showed up for him
zero they showed up for themselves
it's what they believed about america
that got them to travel on a bus for
eight hours to stand in the sun in
washington for
in the middle of august it's what they
believed and it wasn't about
black versus white 25 percent of the
audience was white
dr king believed that there are two
types of laws in this world
those that are made by a higher
authority authority and those that are
made by man
and not until all the laws that are made
by man
are consistent with the laws that are
made by the higher authority will we
live in a just world
it just so happens that the civil rights
movement was the perfect thing
to help him bring his cause to life we
followed not him not for him but for
ourselves
and by the way he gave the i have a
dream speech not the i have a plan
speech
[Music]
listen to politicians now with a
comprehensive 12-point plans and not
inspiring anybody
because there are leaders and there are
those who lead
leaders hold a position of power or
authority
but those who lead inspire us whether
they're individuals or organizations
we follow those who lead not because we
have to
but because we want to we follow those
who lead
not for them but for ourselves
and it's those who start with why that
have the ability
to inspire those around them or find
others
who inspire them thank you very much
[Music]
oh
[Music]
sharing that's video on the human
network
cisco welcome to the human network